[音楽]
[拍手]
どのように彼を解放するつもりですか？
継続
私
ヨーロッパでは文字通り私が持っているこれがあります
見られる準備ができています
[音楽]
プラス
それで
[音楽]
そんなに
か否か
私に
いいえ
Y
[音楽]
しかし
私は彼らを救うために行くつもりです
ああ
それだけ
もうありません
すでにファンがいるのかわかりません
そして1つだけ
[音楽]
か否か
h
[音楽]
Y
アリア
[音楽]
あまりない
あげます
花崗岩の自動ステージはありません
会社をコートする
はい
アメリカン
ef more
私の家に
州投票ジュリトも
歌う方法
私たちも数えます
よりも
[音楽]
はい
Y
[音楽]
他の年があります
午前
[音楽]
同僚ハイメ・ロレット40
これはケースでした
とても機敏な色のシャビ・エルナン
でもそれは素晴らしいことではありません
[音楽]
ああ
前の彼女の絶対照合ステーション
私はブルネットです
[音楽]
私
より大きい
夏はオリジナル
私
しかし、すべてが恐怖とタンパク質であるわけではありません
ツーリング
それ以上のサービスに置かれていません
税務署としてではなく監督するつもりです
プラス
力としてアフリカのすべてにトニマリ
レベル番号であなたの最後の仕事になります
私にはマカレナのガールフレンドがいます
シカゴの子供たちは起こっているテーマを過熱します
デイビスをチェックするためにキルにジャンプする
掘り出し物など
巨人について
トニーヒット
欲望のシオニズム薬剤師はすでに私
疲れた
以上
[音楽]
戦い
彼らは私が行く理論としてより多くを運びます
私が知っているところに明確な顔はありません
家
カルロスアリエルが問題を支配する
でも砂は少なく、このバステイロは
あなたの家と資産を持っている
[音楽]
高速道路ではありません
そのことについて
さあ行こう
[拍手]